Mesoamerican mythology is among the
types of myth that we've yet to begin
exploring but the patrons have decided
that this week's video will be on the
rainbow feathered serpent Quetzal Court
now before I dive into this video I've
seen on those discussing this and when
research of Mesoamerican myth and
Quetzalcoatl it raised the point that I
do feel fairly passionate about because
it's something I wish more people
consider to an approaching mythology
quite often people try to compare modern
storytelling to myths and stories of
thousands of years old I get countless
comments when people telling me they've
heard several versions of a myth and
they want to know which one is correct I
need to tell them which one is Canon
even to this day I still get Percy
Jackson fans telling me that Perseus is
the son of Poseidon and I know this
isn't even the case in Percy Jackson but
it definitely is among the problem
people that read the works of Rick
Riordan and watch these movies based on
mythology and assume there must be Canon
rather than doing their own research and
attempting to learn something they just
assume that everything else is wrong
it's important for us to consider the
way stories were told to thousands of
years ago differ greatly to how stories
are told today to give you an example if
you ought to pick up a copy of Harry
Potter and the Philosopher's Stone it
doesn't matter when you read it you
could have read it on a date was
published or you could read it 10 years
later the contents of that story will
remain largely the same and that's
because it was written by one author and
the same copies were printed on a mass
scale I can't then just pick up a copy
and start telling people version where
Harry turns into a six-headed dragon
steals Voldemort snows and start
scooping out households well I can but
there's a good chance that you know I'm
incorrect and most likely crazy
mythology stem some stories that were
told thousands of years ago these
stories are not told by one author and
they were not printed and posted online
to the masses as these stories traveled
through towns and cities people would
often embellish certain elements they
would twist certain narratives and they
would create a version that related to
them and the people around them
storytelling now has become very static
and it doesn't really change ancient
storytelling however was the exact
opposite changing constantly throughout
time so if you read two or three similar
versions of a particular myth then the
chances are that they're all correct in
their own way now of course you do still
in to play some kind of common sense
when reading mythology if I made a video
tomorrow telling you that Zeus was
actually the god of flamingos and pink
Ferrari so I'd like to think most of you
would know that I was wrong though I'm
sure I'd still get comments along the
lines of oh yes flamingos and pink
Ferraris one you see I already knew all
of this because I read
and as an avid Percy Jackson fan my
knowledge is extensive and I know
everything unlike the rest of you
plebeians I know that Perseus was the
true son of precise this video I don't
even know what this video is anymore on
a serious note for those posted Jackson
fans who've got the knickers in a twist
it's just a joke it's perfectly fine to
enjoy Percy Jackson anyway I think
that's nothing inside check for one
video so let's try and get this video
back on track the most important thing
when reading any kind of mythology is to
keep an open mind understanding these
stories did change over time so I'm sure
some of you may be wondering how does
this relate to Quetzal cohan
I came here for kids of color give me
Quetzalcoatl kids Zuko it is a perfect
example of what I can discuss him
storytelling that changes depending on
the region period of time and the needs
of the people I've never really come
across a data that's been depicted in so
many different ways ranging from the
call of the wind to the god of literally
everything with Mesoamerican mythology
spanning across so many regions I've
seen numerous ways of pronouncing the
name including Quetzal court
get suka wattle and cuckoo clan before
game with the mine interpretation the
name is softer I from to now at terms
Quetzal being the name of the bird that
it's tell feather resembled and koa
meaning snake or serpent for those of
you wondering now what was a language
spoken by the Aztecs and to them cats
will call it translated to mean
feathered serpent the worship of kids
required took place in several occasions
over a large period of time broken up
into much smaller segments the earliest
of these periods was beliefs have been
in 400 BC to 600 AD in the city of
Teotihuacan weather was an enormous
pyramid built in honor of the feathered
serpent this serpent would later be
identified as the Stech God Quetzalcoatl
in the region of Teotihuacan would then
continue from 600 to 900 AD from 900 AD
to 15 1980 the worship has spread to the
region of Cholula and it was during this
period that the date he began to be
widely referred to as Quetzal caught by
his Aztec followers and cuckoo clock to
those in the Mayan areas it is worth
noting in the very first representations
of feathered serpents that we have were
carvings of beaks snakes being flanked
by Quetzal birds and these came from the
Olmec civilization that existed from
1200 BC to 400 BC this meant that they
died at a similar time to wink at Circo
it began being worshipped and tail to
what can during the early period
Quetzalcoatlus seen as a deity
associated of wind rain and vegetation
even at times been seen as a crater of
the world and man
and in later periods jun-hee's worship
interlude around 1200 ad he was seen as
the patron god of priests and merchants
get so caught up went from a good
associated with nature of fertility and
creation to one that was associated to
almost everything depending on the
region you found yourself in he was seen
in dress ly different ways from the god
of the wind to the crater of all and
even a serpentine monster quezacotl was
also seen as a very important god in
regards to agriculture as he was
believed to have been the founder of
corn a crop that the Mesoamerican people
would be extremely thankful for when
Quetzalcoatl other gods created a new
race of people they came to the
realization that there was no food for
these people to eat not wanting mankind
to perish that God scattered across the
lands in search for food
Etsuko it came across a red ant that was
carrying a grain of maize he instantly
knew that corn would be the food of the
Aztec people the ant the dementia
Talcott suckle at that the grain came
from inside the mountain of sustenance
when he eventually reached the mountain
he saw that he could he passed through a
small hole watching the road and to
enter kids who collect transformed
himself into a small black ant and made
his way into the mountain once inside
kids would coax saw that those stacks of
grain as high as a ceiling of the Kevin
he took several of these grains back to
his fellow gods and explained that this
would be how they would feed their
people this story does someone explain
why maize and the whole harvest and
process became so sacred to the Aztec
people gets record will then go on to be
associated of science and all forms of
learning from the creation of books to
calendars to even be identified with the
planet Venus the appearance of
Quetzalcoatl admitted to believe that he
may have been a very early piece of
Mesoamerican duality he's wings in the
ability to fly and that he would have
been seen in a divine manner but he
serpent body was very symbolic of the
earth and this does create a dated that
people can easily relate to and that is
exactly what they did
castlecore it was seen as a creator but
also a hero and protects a lot by many
he was often depicted as a serpent of
plume feathers the color of the rainbow
but he did however also have a human
form he would appear as a bearded man
wearing Jade jewelry with two tubes that
he would blow into creating the wind
there is even a species of dinosaur
named after Quetzalcoatl the
Quetzalcoatlus who were the largest
flying animals of all time it seems like
over the years kid Sequoia was a great
source of pride and inspiration for the
people of Mesoamerica and modern day
central Mexico with so many variations
and interpretations of Quetzalcoatl I'd
certainly encourage you to share any
that you may have come across with me in
the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
in fiction explained